first up avalanche has delivered on a
big time request for hogwarts legacy by
giving fans the ability to link their
wizarding world fan club accounts
formerly known as pottermore to their wb
account for hogwarts legacy this will
bring over both the wand and hogwarts
house that was given to players on the
wizarding world website the fan site
also has a patronus quiz however
avalanche didn't mention whether or not
the patronus would transfer into the
game along with the wand and house at
number two in addition to the account
link announcement avalanche also
revealed special bonuses that will be
granted to players who choose to link
their accounts in the form of these
house fanatic robes as well as this big
skull mask even better the robes will
always match the house you're currently
playing on which is great for players
who are planning on multiple
playthroughs avalanche also confirmed
you can link your account to get the
rewards and still choose not to bring
over your house or wand this is mainly
for players who prefer a different house
or wand than the one they've been given
on the wizarding world website and by
the way guys if you're one of those
people who isn't happy with your result
you can always delete your wizarding
world account sign up again using the
exact same email and retake the quizzes
i would just make sure you do all of
that before you link it to the wb
account for number three with all of the
recent trailers it would be easy to
forget some of the smaller updates
avalanche has given starting with an
updated faq they officially confirmed no
playable quidditch which we reported on
here back in july the updated faq also
has an interesting answer regarding
morality in hogwarts legacy it states
hogwarts legacy does not have a morality
system but players will encounter
various quests and storylines that will
influence the witch or wizard they
choose to become considering we already
know we'll have an opportunity to decide
between at least a few different choices
throughout missions this update has left
me with more questions than answers do
they simply mean there's no system that
tracks our morality and choices as in
you won't forge a completely new path
whether you choose to play completely
good or completely evil or does it mean
our choices won't matter at all i find
the latter hard to believe considering
the reveal trailer said this the choices
you make now
will define the legacy
of the conference
and there's also an additional faq post
that states players will also encounter
quests and scenarios that will pose
difficult choices and determine what
they stand for i mean what's the point
in standing for something if it has no
impact at all on the story quest please
let it actually have an impact on the
story speaking of quests as we move on
to number four here the trailer showing
off sebastian's sallow's quest line was
confirmed by community manager chandler
wood to be an entirely optional quest
and then in a recent playstation blog
post wood also confirmed optional quest
lines for both natsionai and poppy
sweeting the gryffindor and hufflepuff
companion respectively those are the
only three companions that have been
revealed so far which has fans
desperately wanting to know is there a
ravenclaw companion and if so why
haven't we found out about them yet
number five in a recent sony state of
play we got a new trailer for the
haunted hogsmeade shop quest line yet
another optional quest in hogwarts
legacy unfortunately for pc xbox and
switch players this quest is a timed
exclusive on playstation platforms for a
full calendar year i suppose on the
bright side at least we found out that
it's only a timed quest and not a fully
exclusive quest to playstation for
playstation gamers you should know this
does not require a pre-order or a
specific version of the game if you're
playing on the playstation platform
you'll have access to this quest now
this is just me here but i would assume
this will eventually be released to all
players in february 2024 but it hasn't
been confirmed yet just how avalanche
will handle a possible rollout to the
other platforms once that exclusivity
with sony runs out as for number six
while the quest doesn't require
pre-ordering wb and playstation are
offering a pre-order bonus to entice
players and it comes in the form of a
felix felicis potion recipe according to
wood in a playstation blog post the
liquid luck potion will reveal gear
chests on the minimap for one in-game
day but it is just the recipe players
will still need to brew the potion with
help from their potions lessons and the
potions stations in the room of
requirement oh and by the way yes would
also just confirm that hogwarts legacy
will have a map as well as day night
cycles something we were already pretty
sure was going to be in but nice to have
it confirmed here number seven the
haunted hogsmeade shop trailer also
introduced us to three new characters
the first being cassandra mason a name
that was leaked two years ago on actress
julia farino's imdb page farino is also
set to voice a character by the name of
helen thistlewood who seems a likely
candidate for the herbology professor as
for the other two characters in the
trailer we only hear their voices but if
you watch playstation's version of the
trailer with the captions turned on
you'll see their names revealed as penny
and fast studio penny sounds like a
small girl or more likely a house elf
considering she refers to madame mason
as her mistress she has had rotten bad
luck with the last few tenants
fastidio on the other hand sounds like a
malevolent being and considering that
the shop is haunted many fans have
guessed he could be a poltergeist to his
taken up residence in the shop those who
came before you just could not seem to
escape the darkness
now for number eight with the haunted
hogsbeat shop trailer avalanche also
revealed yet another in-game costume in
the form of the shopkeeper's cosmetic
set completing the haunted hogsmeade
quest will reward players with this set
in addition to a shop of their own where
they can sell items and gear at better
rates than anywhere else unfortunately
it also seems this shop is only for
playstation and the official hogwarts
legacy twitter account actually
responded to a question with the
following answer completion of the
haunted hogsmeade shop quest is the only
way to receive an in-game hogsmeade shop
to own the quest is exclusive to
playstation consoles through february
10th 2024. now just my own little
interjection here i think it's really
interesting wording here because of the
fact that they say sell items and gear
at better rates than anywhere else to me
that implies that other players will at
least have somewhere to sell the items
and gear that we have it just won't be
in the form of this dedicated shop that
we own in hogsmeade and really until
someone outside of avalanche wb or
playstation is able to actually see this
and play through this and comment on it
then we really aren't going to know just
how significant of a detail this
actually is i mean it could be a very
small minor thing or it could actually
be a significant thing in terms of
owning our own shop i mean is this some
sort of passive thing that just kind of
happens in the background once you have
the shop unlocked or will it have more
active things that you will have to
physically go into the shop to do in
order to sell these items at number nine
there have been two hogwarts legacy
books listed on amazon for quite some
time the art and making of hogwarts
legacy from inside editions as well as
hogwarts legacy the official game guide
the latter recently saw an update with a
full cover reveal for the first time the
artwork is similar to the box art of the
standard edition of the game however it
features a different student and also a
character holding their wand in their
left hand i'm pretty sure this marks the
first time we've seen a character in
hogwarts legacy with a wand in their
left hand and this now has some fans
wondering is this confirmation that
lefties will be able to play the game
with their dominant hand as their wand
arm now as much as i would like to say
yes i certainly would not take this
cover art as confirmation of that
considering that artists can take
creative liberties to make something
that will look the best and may not
necessarily be 100 accurate to the game
and depending on code and even the level
design and enemy design of the game
sometimes these things can be very
simple to just flip and have the
character use their other hand but then
there are other times that it's way more
difficult than you would imagine i
remember it was a huge deal with the
legend of zelda twilight princess which
was a gamecube game originally but then
also launched on the nintendo wii well
in the wii version link was right-handed
because nintendo had the wii remote and
knew that most people were right-handed
whereas in the gamecube version link was
still left-handed but what's really
interesting about that is that the games
had to be complete mirrors of one
another so rather than everything being
exactly the same the world was
essentially completely flipped or
mirrored in the wii version with link
now using the sword in his right hand
now avalanche has also released four
glorious trailers all in 4k resolution
showcasing the four hogwarts common
rooms we'd seen each room briefly before
but these trailers give us our best look
so far at all of the incredible detail
avalanche is including here ravenclaw
features an orderly bright common room
with plenty of spots for studying
gryffindor is a welcoming and
comfortable space that shows off school
spirit house pride and a remembrance of
former gryffindors with numerous
portraits hufflepuff has nailed that
warm earthy feel with plenty of areas
that encourage social interaction and
numerous plants that help bring life to
the space and while slytherin may be in
the dungeons the vast windows looking
out into the black lake let plenty of
light filter through you'll find bizarre
relics strange items and what has to be
the most jaw-dropping entrance of all
four with the slytherin common room and
all four of these common rooms have so
many amazing details and tiny little
secrets for you to find i've actually
done full breakdown videos of each
hogwarts house common room so take a
look at the videos on your screen now
and jump straight to my breakdowns of
your favorite hogwarts house as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon